ah Hodor
hey youtubers it's Charlie so you guys
requested a new video on Dragonstone
history so I talked about that first
then I talk about the new promo with the
costume so just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on the show
so far if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything
I do Game of Thrones every week there's
going to be a whole bunch of awesome
stuff happening once the season starts
and there's a new round of the book
giveaway that I'll explain at the end of
the video so we all saw Daenerys in the
season 7 promo
she is in Dragonstone in the throne room
there is an actual throne room inside
Dragonstone we just haven't visited it
yet because when we were there in season
2 with Stannis he didn't spend a lot of
time there he's been most of his time in
the chamber of the painted table which
is named for the giant table of Westeros
that Aegon the conquerer had built so on
a lot of levels Daenerys is paralleling
a lot of Aegon the conquerors stories
the way he came to Westeros the way he
conquered the Seven Kingdoms really it
was six kingdoms and Dorne that he
conquered but luckily Daenerys has
already forged an alliance with tor the
thing is is that George R Martin tends
to subvert tropes like that where
characters follow the path of their
ancestors but then something goes
completely sideways so of course the
narrative story won't be exactly like
Aegon the conquerors but so much of
Daenerys his family's history is tied up
in the history of Dragonstone it's
totally fascinating she was even born
there during the last month of Robert's
rebellion her brother Viserys was
crowned king by their mother on her
deathbed so as a newborn baby she was
named a princess of Dragonstone but
sadly they fled to the east while Robert
was crowned king of the Seven Kingdoms
so Dragonstone itself was a Valyrian
outpost that dates to about 200 years
before the doom so this is well after
the Andal invasion just to place it in
the timeline of Game of Thrones you have
the long night the building of the wall
which is about six thousand years ago
and right after that you have the rise
of the Valyrian freehold sort of
coinciding with the great migration of
the Andals to Westeros you can imagine
that his valyrian started to conquer
dragons and conquer the east that
everybody who didn't become a slave
tried to bail mostly the Andals they
traded one war with the Valyrians for
another
or with the first men when they got to
Westeros the show is famous for
compressing time but the war with the
first men that the Andals had lasted for
centuries this was all still thousands
of years before the Valerians turned
Dragonstone into an outpost the
Valerians continued to rise in about 600
years before the doom the ruin or people
Nymeria in the ten thousand ships they
migrated to what is now door formed that
nation jumped forward about five hundred
years the Valyrians are reaching the
height of their power they annexed this
small island at the mouth of Blackwater
Bay on the east coast of Westeros one of
the minor households of the Valyrian
freehold the Targaryens take control of
it and start building a castle there
fashioning it to look like dragons when
you see dragon stone here it's been
added to on over the centuries once the
Targaryens migrated there and made it
their permanent home before the doom of
Valyria but before then it was just this
outpost that they would use to control
trade in that region the most striking
thing about it is the fact that it's
built on a volcanic island there are a
lot of secrets of Dragonstone that have
been lost over time a lot of people
believe that there are still dragon eggs
hidden beneath the castle where the
Dragons used to roost but one of the
other big secrets that was lost over
time was the secret of the masonry they
used to build it so it's way more ornate
than the show has made it out to be
there hasn't been a lot of exterior
shots the hope is is that during season
seven they'll spend some of those big
dollars to do the CG to show it off
right so not only is it covered in stone
dragons it's also got basilisk
cockatrices demons Griffin's hellhounds
manticores minotaurs wyverns in all
manner of other demon like creatures so
there's this mind-blowing level of
detail that you don't really learn about
through Stannis's character because he
spends most of his time complaining
about dragon stone because he feels like
his rightful places at storms end but
when robert was named king he gave
storms end to Renly and put Stannis on
Dragonstone so he always viewed it as a
slight there's this famous quote during
the lore in the histories that you find
on the season 2 DVD where he narrates
unjustly I was blamed and stripped of
our family's castle of storms and and
given Dragonstone in its stead over the
years whenever
I demanded my rights restored Robert
would remind me of the islands royal
pedigree in pretend that he was doing me
an honor as if I were one of his tavern
girls to be so easily deceived and
dismissed but Robert is dead in I
Stannis Baratheon and the rightful king
of Westeros let the usurpers and
traitors sit on the Iron Throne from
Dragonstone I will be the dagger at
their throat so you can see that was way
before he ever made his move during the
War of the five kings when he was still
deciding what he was going to do
Robert was dead I'm going to make my
move and take my rightful place on the
Iron Throne but because at the time
Stannis was a relatively minor character
you only get quick shots of a lot of the
rooms in Dragonstone
the room of the painted table is really
where he spent most of his time so
that's why you see some of the designs
like the dragon here carved into the
wall
that looks like he's eating him so this
is just a magic of framing shots on Game
of Thrones there'll be a lot of this
during season seven so when Daenerys is
sitting in certain places just look at
the way they frame shots it's almost
like she's sitting inside a dragon
itself but what happened is is that
before the doom of Valyria
the Targaryen Zin the Valyrian freehold
used dragon stone is a way to levy tax
on ships that would pass through so they
just used it for trade purposes and to
keep an eye on what was going on in
Westeros just to remind them of their
power but you have to imagine it is one
of the lesser forts along the wall so
the wall itself has many different forts
not all of them are as big as Castle
black Castle black is just the main one
right here at the center so that's sort
of the way that the Valyrian view dragon
stone when it was first built it was
just one of the lesser force that they
would use to keep an eye on a different
part of the world just in case something
happened but then something really big
did happen a little over a hundred years
before the doom Dan is the dreamer the
daughter of a naar Targaryen the current
head of the household at the time had a
vision of the doom he divested himself
of all of his holdings in the freehold
packed up everything he owned his family
all of his dragons and they migrated to
Dragonstone permanently within a hundred
years the 14 flames all erupting causing
the doom of Valyria making the
Targaryens the de facto remnants of the
Valyrian Empire so all the precious
minerals all the valerian steels
- drying up if you wonder they actually
did trade balerion steel with Westeros
so there was like a small trickle that
would flow in through Dragonstone
remember it was used for trade but it
was such a precious commodity that there
was a very little of it so there was
Valyrian steel in Westeros before Aegon
the conquerer was born but it was still
very very rare Aegon wasn't born to
Danice the dreamer till decades later
remember she was the one that had the
visions of the doom of Valyria so dennis
Daenerys there's a lot of parallels
going on here not that Daenerys is going
to have a son named Aegon but he did get
involved with conflicts in the east as
he slowly took power he married his two
sisters and then got involved with some
of the larger conflicts in Westeros but
growing up he did visit different parts
of the kingdom and became fascinated
with it enough to Commission the painted
table the table that Stannis sits at all
the time so this was built long before
he chose to conquer the Seven Kingdoms
but I've already done a couple videos
about Aegon actually conquering the
Seven Kingdoms so I'll add links at the
end of this but you guys can let me know
in the comments when do you think that
the nearest is going to make landfall at
Dragonstone and make it her home there's
still a lot of things that she has to
accomplish during season seven we have
to deal with euron greyjoy
we have to deal with Cersei before we
ever focus on what's happening north of
the wall but Dragonstone itself is just
such an important part of Westeros
history and what Daenerys has to do that
it's going to be so much fun to see it
from different angles and everybody
talks about how much money they're
spending on season seven hopefully they
shelled out for a bunch of CG to show it
off in its full majesty
but a lot of you are asking about the
new faces promo they released an
expanded version of that video that I
did earlier this week for everybody
doing the HBO sound so tyrion is wearing
his full Targaryen uniform handed the
king
looks amazing his costume was one of my
new favorites we see more from Team
Cersei everybody's wondering about Hodor
why is he in the promo does that mean
he's still alive I think it's just
because he's a really big character and
they want you to remember him like hey
look this was a big thing last year
remember and technically he's not dead
so you could still say that he's alive
but we see Arya for the first time and
she almost looks like she's wearing a
leather version of cereal Pharrell's
costume
so it's sort of the Jon Snow thing where
he's starting to dress more like a
classic stark Orias dressing in more
classic Westerosi clothing albeit with a
water dancer twist just invoking a lot
of that imagery so let me know in the
comments who's your favorite new costume
in this faces promo and what's going to
happen next is my next bonus video
unless they drop new footage is going to
be about Varys the spider everybody's
been asking for a Varys video so I'll
try to get that out as fast as possible
but there is a new round of the book
giveaway I'm giving away copies of the
enhanced editions all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video about Game of Thrones
related stuff congratulations to last
week's giveaway winner wedge thx please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details so click here to watch the
season 7 promo again and click here for
my Aegon the conquerer video thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video